Supongamos que trabajo en un restaurante,
donde me pagan 10 dólares la hora,
pero ademas de eso, gano propinas por hora.
Esta expresión de aquí, representa lo que
gano yo, en una hora dada.
Ahora, podemos notar que la cantidad de propinas,
puede cambiar drásticamente de una hora a otra,
puede cambiar, pues por ejemplo, a la hora de la comida hay mucha gente, mis propinas suben,
mientras que una o dos horas después
ya hay menos clientes y entonces mis propinas bajan.
Entonces, la propina aquí, toda esta palabra,
la consideramos una variable,
puede cambiar de un momento a otro.
Así por ejemplo, en un momento dado, en el
momento de la comida que hay mucha gente,
podría estar recibiendo, digamos, 30 dólares
de propina, hay mucha gente, gano 30 dólares
de propina, así es que en esa hora mis ingresos
totales son de 10 más 30 dólares,
vamos a ponerlo aquí, en esa hora mis ingresos
totales son de 10 más las propinas, es decir,
10 más 30 dólares,
así es que eso va a ser igual...
déjame hacerlo con otro color..
esto es igual a 40 dólares.
Ahora, supongamos que a la siguiente hora,
los clientes bajan, ya pasó la hora de la comida,
quizás el restaurante de al lado
tiene una gran oferta y entonces mis propinas
descienden drásticamente a digamos,
5 dólares en esa hora.
Ahora, regresando a esta expresión, mis ingresos
durante esa hora son 10 dólares, mi salario por hora,
más los 5 dólares de propinas, lo que me da un total de ingresos durante esa hora de 15 dólares.
Como puedes ver en esta expresión, el valor
de mis ingresos cambia,
de acuerdo al valor de la variable propinas.
Ahora tú no verás que se usan las palabras
completas en álgebra para designar variables,
a los matemáticos nos da flojera usar palabras
completas entonces usamos solo letras,
quizás entonces en este contexto en este ejemplo
veremos que la ecuación se representaría
como 10 más "p", donde "p" representa
las propinas que recibo en una hora.
Y entonces,
¿qué pasa cuando "p" es igual a 30?
Bueno, cuando "p" es igual a 30...
déjame escribirlo aquí abajo...
cuando "p" es igual a 30, recibo...
aquí tengo "p" igual a 30, así es que recibo
10 más 30 = 40 dólares durante esa hora.
¿Qué pasa cuando "p" es igual a 5?
Cuando "p" es igual a 5, recibo 10 más "p",
que ahora es 5, 10 más 5 = 15 dólares durante esa hora.
Ahora, quiero que quede claro, no necesariamente
tenía que haber sido "p",
no necesariamente tenía que haber sido una letra, aunque en álgebra tradicionalmente usamos una letra.
Podríamos haber escrito como 10 más "x",
donde "x" son las propinas por hora,
aunque no es tan natural como la letra "p" de propinas,
o también podríamos haberlo escrito como 10 más...
digamos... ¡estrella!
donde estrella representa las propinas por
hora, aunque esto no es tan intuitivo,
pero espero que esto te haya dado una idea general de lo que es una variable.
Simplemente es un símbolo...
simplemente es un símbolo,
que representa valores que cambian, valores que varían y es por eso que le llamamos variable.